hey 42 here over the past 3,500 years
mankind has been at war with itself to
various degrees pretty much constantly
in fact we've only managed two hundred
and sixty-eight years of world peace in
all that time because there's always
some other group of people with land
that you want a god you dislike or just
because it's Monday and we're getting
really good at war the 20th century was
a record breaker with over 100 million
dead people proving that we really have
turned into pros
none of this swords and horseback
nonsense anymore but we're also more
civilized on twig only a barbarian will
cut a prisoner's tongue out and put
their head onto a stick a drone and some
laser-guided missiles are a far more
cultured way of doing things and since
we fancied ourselves as civilized we
decided to draw up a rule book about
what you can and cannot do when it comes
to killing millions of people I know but
there's a right in a wrong way to do
this so lock up your gear teens and hide
away your mustard gas because you're not
allowed to use them anymore you naughty
tyrant as we discover what is a war
crime
for thousands of years there have been
rules both written and unwritten about
how warfare should be practiced the
Mahabharata an epic poem from ancient
India contains a passage saying war
should be waged for the sake of conquest
one should not be enraged towards an
enemy who is not trying to kill them
this is the ancient Indian way of saying
don't hate the player hate the game the
Bible also contains passages on war such
as banning people from cutting down
trees outside the city that they're
laying siege to apparently thou shalt
not kill was open to so much
interpretation that's in the sub-clauses
it's even covered gardening before a
massacre but the earliest record we have
of punishment for a war crime which
wasn't just a Victor's punishing the
losers was when peter von hagen buck
would be headed by the holy roman empire
for his treatment of civilians during an
uprising in bree sack in 1474 the reason
they said was that's his crimes were
those he as a knight was deemed to have
a duty to prevent it's also the earliest
example of a case involving command
responsibility since he claimed
unsuccessfully that he was just
following orders the first international
war crime agreement signed was to
Strasbourg agreement of the 27th of
August 1675 it was between France and
the Holy Roman Empire which is this
point was basically Germany to forbid
the use of poison bullets now you'd
think that this was the earliest form of
chemical warfare was in fact it had been
happening for over 2,000 years in 600 BC
the Athenians used a heart toxin taken
from the healable plant to poison the
city of kur are during a siege around
250 AD
the Persians battled the Romans in Syria
by burning sulfur and bitumen to
suffocate them and in 1250 when the
Chinese were fighting Genghis Khan they
made bombs out of gunpowder feces and a
variety of poisons such as arsenic and a
kunai
routes which caused nausea and
convulsions
what a lovely sounding cocktail but I
think I'll take a martini Thanks
at the end of the 19th century many of
the major powers were beginning to think
that maybe there was a better way to do
things and they decided to adopt an
international version of Lieber code
which had been signed by Abraham Lincoln
after the American Civil War it outlawed
the use of torture to get compressions
killing prisoners using poisons and
putting proximity mines on respawn
locations if you were playing Goldeneye
russian tsar nicholas ii was
instrumental in setting up the Hague
Convention of 1899 where a lot of this
was agreed upon and signed by 26
countries it also forbade bullets that
expanded on impact using balloons for
bombing and they also kindly agreed not
to attack marked hospital ships there
was a follow-up in 1907 that covered a
lot more maritime law once we had all
those laws neatly written out on paper
we decided to celebrate by breaking them
all in the horrific slaughter that was
world war one where mustard gas filled
the trenches prisoners were used as
forced labor and nobody gave a flying
monkey about any of the laws of combat
Henri Denault was a Swiss businessman
who became the first recipient of the
Nobel Peace Prize in 1901 for his
humanitarian work which led to the 1864
Geneva Convention and the setting up of
the Red Cross the first Geneva
Convention agreed to protect all the
people not actively trying to kill each
other such as the wounded the civilians
the shipwrecked and prisoners of war we
needed multiple other Geneva Conventions
over the next 100 years since each new
war that passed
proved that we were absolutely terrible
actually following them but nonetheless
they are the cornerstone of most current
humanitarian law now if you break a law
in your own country that it's generally
clear what the punishment is going to be
but none of these conventions have clear
punishments written into them so how do
we know if they really work
I think you probably already know the
answer they don't it's not to say that
they don't have a value we have to have
some common agreement on what is
acceptable or not during war but they
are extremely difficult to actually
enforce if you look at World War two
then in Nuremberg trials famously held
various Nazi officers accountable for
their actions but what if the ten
thousand prisoners who died of
dehydration and malnutrition in the ran
wiesen log of prison camps run by the
Americans in occupied Germany or how
about the 25 thousand civilians who died
when the British fire bombed Dresden or
the hundreds of thousands possibly
millions of Germans raped by Soviets and
other Allied forces after Berlin fell
yes I know it's hard to believe what the
Allies weren't all goody two-shoes this
was war after all even now the Allies
are pretty stubborn about dealing with
what they got up to and tend to ignore
the atrocities that they committed
during war it's often been said that the
victorious write the history books but
they also dictate their own punishments
or Lykov in most cases the Japanese are
one of the few countries that admit it's
two breaches of the Geneva Convention
particularly to surround engage in
nations such as South Korea and China
but an apology is mostly all that
happened and I'm not quite sure that a
fear of saying sorry is going to keep
Kim Jong Un's
chubby finger of the nuclear button so
has any progress actually been made are
we any closer to really enforcing these
rules of engagement well maybe a little
when it comes to using illegal weapons
we've realized that the best way to stop
people is to not let them have them in
the first place I know just like if you
own a gun then you're probably more
likely to use it than someone who
doesn't own a gun when it comes to
nuclear weapons the five members of the
UN Security Council possess them legally
that's China Russia France the UK on the
US and only four other countries have
them that we know of India Pakistan is
and North Korea but they are not part of
the treaty so there's not a lot we can
really do about it except ask them
really really nicely not to end the
world but according to the treaties for
chemical and biological weapons all
stockpiles should have been destroyed no
one should have kept some spares lying
around in case of a rainy day and any
country in the treaty is supposed to be
able to ask the UN to send inspectors to
any other country to check that they're
not hiding sarin gas behind the biskits
for many of the wars in recent memory
including the current one in Syria the
use or suspected possession of chemical
and biological weaponry has been the key
reason given for the US and British
interventions and as you all know all of
those wars have been a resounding
success and everyone lived happily ever
after
so yeah international war conventions
really do work it's all totally fine and
I'm just building that bunker and my
garden for for no other reason I swear
thanks for watching
subscribe for more thoughty2 if we go
back to the Middle Ages or even all the
way back to the Roman Empire was life
ever any better for this lakebed is
littered with hundreds of hundreds of
skeletal human remains